this technology can change a ton of  people's lives who are watching this  right now no different than Tick Tock  and YouTube and Twitter and a lot of the  [ __ ] that I've talked about over the  last 15 years that have really helped  people uh you have to check out chat GPT  um link is in the bio this is AI done in  a way that is really profound uh I think  you're gonna be completely blown away  this is your head will explode when you  play with it it made me feel the way I  first saw a search engine  um I was like wait a minute I can get  all the information from the world from  this this is profound and most of all if  you're a writer if you write blogs for  Content creators  edible for people like code this is  incredible and for many more things and  use cases that are coming this is  incredible what's most incredible is  this is going to be your first taste of  AI that really blows you away I think  like the link in the Bible play with it